quick sound check Malcolm tell me what
you had for breakfast please
I had a cappuccino and a third of a
cross on the root of a crystal and do
you divvy it up over three days or is
that just was it a bad croissant
no I love croissants but I feel like one
I don't I think he wants you to eat a
minimum the the absolute minimum in the
morning I don't think you should eat a
lot in the morning we will commit omit
rules we will explore that further thank
you at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking can I ask
you a personal question
no it is soon I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time
wealthfront as I mentioned since it's
using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
this episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies calm this is the
training system that I am most obsessed
with at the moment and I don't get paid
any Commission's or anything like that
you may have heard coach summer on the
podcast to design the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming I've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and I feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out
gymnastic bodies calm forward-slash Tim
if you go to that landing page gymnastic
bodies calm forward-slash Tim you can
take a look at the fundamentals course
which I'll help you diagnose your
weakest points areas to improve etc and
I highly encourage you take a look at
this bodyweight training system it is
incredible gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim
hello boys and girls ladies and
squirrels it is a late night in New York
City and the echo is from within the
walls of a fine establishment otherwise
known as a hotel that I am calling my
abode for this evening Molly is curled
up all the children are snug in their
beds with visions of sugarplums no
that's not why we're here
this is the Tim Ferriss show and welcome
to another episode where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class experts and
world-class performers so that we can
borrow their habits routines tools test
them ourselves and prove how we perform
in our personal and professional lives
and this episode features Malcolm
Gladwell I've wanted to interview
Malcolm quite a long time and it finally
happened we had a proper sit-down we've
bumped into each other before a few
times but this was the first in-depth
conversation and we cover a lot Malcolm
Gladwell at Gladwell on Twitter
say hi is the author of five New York
Times bestsellers mega bestsellers the
tipping point blink outliers with dog
saw and David and Goliath he's been
named one of the 100 most influential
people by Time magazine
he has explored how ideas spread
decision-making the roots of success the
advantages of disadvantages and in his
latest podcast project revisionist
history which I highly recommend
Gladwell examines the way the passage of
time changes and enlightens our
understanding of the world around us he
also revisits certain aspects of history
that perhaps we should take another look
at and in this wide-ranging in-depth in
person conversation we cover a ton
including his research and writing
process how he learned to ask good
questions favorite books routines habits
tools how he puts together or pulls
together rather seemingly unrelated
stories into a cohesive theme and
eventually a book his obsession with
running why he eats as little as
possible in the mornings and much more
it is highly tactical there are some
hilarious and great stories some very
surprising stuff that I am sure you have
not heard anywhere else
that is all I have to say about that so
please say hi to him on Twitter at
Gladwell and I hope you enjoy this
conversation as much as I did thanks for
listening
Malcolm welcome to the show thank you
Tim I really appreciate Megan the time
and I know we've bumped into each other
a few times over the years I remember I
want to say the first time was at a
salon that Peter teal put together not
like religion ethics and morality or
something like that
oh right is ages ago and years ago years
ago and I remember showing up and Erin
Hoffman who had co-hosted the event as a
friend of mine was like hey would you
mind just like improving and speaking at
this event for a few minutes about X Y
or Z we haven't decided on the topic set
and I said sure then I showed up and I
see Malcolm Gladwell I see some
award-winning you know voted favorite
Teacher of the decade Harvard professor
and that's when I started drinking
really heavily so I suspect it was a
poor performance on my part in
preparation for this because I've been
looking forward to it I paying Stephen
Dubner
freakanomics mutual friend and his
response was short it was fun
exclamation point he's a great talker he
likes to talk about writing running fast
cars not golf being Canadian sorry gotta
run something along those lines and he
took off and I was planning to speak
with you about at least one or two of
those and I thought we could start with
writing okay what have been the easiest
and hardest books for you to write well
uh it's an interesting question I don't
find writing or to the extent that I
find writing I link hard and fun so if
it's not hard it's not fun so I never
think about writing in terms of hard and
easy I think about it in terms of fun
and not fun so which one was the most
fun probably the last two mostly because
I wrote the first book while I was still
working pretty much full-time at The New
Yorker so I just was didn't have a lot
of time and now makes it less fun you
can't really kind of savor and
appreciate it but the last two I took as
much time as I needed
and deliberately dragged it out because
I was enjoying myself so much so I think
that's probably the last two books were
the were there so that does that mean
the last two of the hardest hardest
slashes fun yes I think they were
because I was trying to do tell better
stories I became convinced about 15
years ago or so that I if I was to
develop as a writer I had to be a better
storyteller and so those the outliers in
what the dog saw were books where I was
really really trying to do a better job
and I'm sorry and David and lithe where
I was really trying to be a do a better
job of telling good stories who do you
are there any people come to mind
fictional or otherwise who are good
storytellers yeah
Michael Lewis is the gold standard
Michael Lewis um and that's I was
actually in reading Michael Lewis that I
realized that I wanted to be you you
can't be him any more than you can you
know you can't say I watch Steph Curry
play basketball and I decided that's the
kind of basketball player I want to be
like you you know you can try and you
can be inspired by him you could pattern
your play after him but you can't be him
that only you know that's impossible so
I have tried it I was inspired by
Michael Lewis to get better but I am not
on his level I was well I think both of
you are very very good at taking what
could be dense impenetrable material or
overwhelming material and making it a
story that is easy to consume I mean as
storytelling and consuming machines Oh
he tells I tell a million stories in one
book he tells one story that's so much
harder what makes that harder cuz you
have to go to a level and complexity and
have confidence what happens is that I
lose confidence in the reason I tell
lots of stories and I don't the
confidence to keep going with the same
one I think oh I everyone must be losing
interest
I got a switch to do something else now
Michael doesn't have that problem I mean
he he has the kind of panache to say I'm
going to tell you a story about a guy
basically trying to do hi-c can't take
on the high speed traders and I will
we're going to
this for 200 pages and you're gonna love
it like I I can't start with that that's
part of the reason I also write my books
in and I'm not in any way comparing
myself to you or you have every right to
tonight why I'm a writer who dad
or I'm a teacher who dabbles incorrect
and sometimes put stuff down that's
intelligible but the way that I tend to
nonlinearly write my books and encourage
people to consume it in a nonlinear ways
precisely for that reason because I
worry that if in some cases I can keep
something interesting for 15-20 pages
but I lack the confidence that I can do
it for 200 or 300 yeah it takes em you
got to be you got to be good to pull off
that feat particularly with the sorts of
topics that he chooses which are you
know esoteric he wrote he would a
gripping thriller about credit swaps and
derivatives I mean that's not easy not
easy at all I I mean then you have
sabermetrics and he's so consistent the
next question I would ask was related to
the perennial topic of course but
writer's block and or anything that you
might consider something like that and
it's related to the kind of module
choose-your-own-adventure like way in
which I write myself which is one way
that I can put something on the Shelf of
I'm having trouble with it and move on
to something else
it doesn't have to be sequential do you
run into writer's block if so how does
that manifest and what do you what do
you do or do you get stuck well I don't
you know I worked for 10 years at a
newspaper and if that experience teaches
you anything it said you can't have
writer's block I mean you quite
literally can't I mean the story will be
you'll start the story at 10:30 and it's
do it 4 or 4:30 or whatever back in
those days there's hard deadlines so you
can't have I mean sitting with
unthinkable I mean you know the luxury
and if you went to your bosses and you
said I'm blocked on this story they
would look at you like you were insane
no like take off your beret
he's a poetry yeah but you know según so
it's like there's not even an issue so I
mean I I did used to have these issues
and then I went to the wash suppose Elia
you get
in a hurry have any pretensions you have
about your writing you just you just
keep typing I mean it's not there's no
kind of alternative and luckily that I
have those habits that I caught that I
learned over though that ten years at
The Washington Post I just have stayed
with me and so I I never and also you
know writing to me is only writing a
book is maybe 20 percent writing an 80
percent organization logistics so I will
think about something for every hour I
spend writing I spend three hours
thinking about writing so usually when
I'm writing it's first of all it's a
tiny period and secondly it's all worked
out already I mean I'm just putting down
on the page what has already been kind
of figured out in my head where does
weird now is that true also for a
shorter piece and say The New Yorker
yeah I will have not all of it but I
know what I'm doing before I start or I
know what the pieces are could you give
an example of any piece or any book
where it started and what the process
was for you in getting to the point that
you're then putting words down on paper
and the reason I ask is that I am
fascinated by structure I don't think
I'm particularly gifted at it but I did
long ago took a class at John McPhee one
year oh yeah
colleagues staff writer at The New
Yorker and his his grasp and approach to
structure is just incredible
at least the way that he visualizes his
structure but he has very particular
process I can't follow his say day to
day schedule just basically sitting in
front of a blank piece of paper from
like 8:00 in the morning to 6:00 p.m.
whether anything's written or not which
would lead me to just want to throw my
head through a window what uh can you
give us any origins story of any yeah so
uh it's some are easy I did a story for
The New Yorker last fall about a school
shooter in Minnesota and there I that
was super easy because I wanted to write
about school shootings I start rooting
around the internet and I find this
criminal complaint and transcript
transcript of a interrogation of a kid
who was caught basically in the act
would be school shooter caught in the
act and he gives his SEC 60 pages and
it's his absolutely extraordinary
account of what he was thinking and what
he was planning to do and why he was
planning to do it and when you find
something like that I mean your job is
done
right so you're like oh I'm gonna tell
this story and then I'm going to step
away only to kind of put that story in
broader context so those are rare that
wrote itself that's rare
what's harder are things that are have a
less of a less obvious structure so my
book outliers began with there was a
chapter in that book about Jewish
lawyers about this curious fact that the
group the could of core of Jewish
lawyers in New York City who rose to
prominence in the 60s and 70s and
basically kind of take over corporate
law in the city all had strikingly
similar backgrounds and so that's the
first chapter I wrote in outliers that
sort of is where I began that book
because I met one of them one of those
lawyers was the father of a friend of
mine madam when I talked to him I was
like oh wait a minute
there are all of his buddies they're all
from the same part of the Bronx they all
were born in pact in the same year the
almond City College they all went to NYU
Law School they all started in the same
kind of firms I mean it's the same story
again and again and again and out of if
you think about it I mean if if one were
I don't know why one would but if one
were to study that book outliers you
would discover that almost all of the
themes that I explore in that book are
present in the story of the Jewish
lawyers so everything is there so I
reported that story I wrote that chapter
I thought about it like oh okay it's all
all the strands I'm interested in are
there I'm gonna pull out strand after
strand and write chapters about them did
it start off in your head as the as a
chapter in a prospective book or was it
a standalone no it was
I wonder write a book about successful
people and so it was always going to be
a chapter in the book but it was it was
just a great I don't know a lucky place
to start because when you could start
with the with one of those I don't know
if that's the best chapter in the book
but it is is functionally the most
important chapter in the book had all
the macro elements in the integral and
that that's the gold center when you can
have that kind of you can begin on that
kind of note other ones have been much
more difficult because they haven't had
that now let's say you have that story
you have that chapter how do you go out
or go about rather collecting and let me
take a step backwards how did you what
tools were you using to query and find
this sixty page transcript of the would
be school shooter I don't remember I was
I was screwing around on the internet um
as interested in school shootings I
don't even know how I mean this was
there was zero coverage of this case it
was in the local Minnesota press that's
it I'd never heard of it he didn't the
kid was caught before he did anything so
it never made national headlines and the
transcript is just on the website of the
local da so it's like the end I don't
know how I found it I can't remember
I just fab you so curiously I be so
glorious know how to I just was one of
those but other cases like in my podcast
for example one of the episodes I like
the most two episodes actually touching
this question so one is an episode I
think it's the eighth or ninth episode
is called generous orthodoxy and it's
the story of a ninety eight year old
Mennonite pastor in Lancaster
Pennsylvania who takes on his church and
I come from a very men in that area in a
Ontario many of my friends and brothers
friends are Mennonites my brother's
event at night my parents quit you know
I know that world really well I go home
at Christmas and my everyone's talking
about this guy I want to say everyone is
only number of Mennonites in North
America is very small it's a very small
you know Evangelical Protestant sect
denomination but they're talking about
this letter this guy wrote it's got a
lot of Facebook Likes for them you know
and he's 98 and so I read the letter
like oh my goodness what an
extraordinary letter so I tracked down
the guy I interview him like a week
later going to drive out to Lancaster
and I said look at the transcript and I
say well what's this about and I
realized that what it's about is how to
protest he's a guy who is so wise and uh
it's an extraordinary interview it's
like again I did nothing it's one of
those cases where he's just amazing I
stumbled into this it's a it's ten
o'clock at night on a cold Saturday
night in January I'm in this little tiny
house on the Turnpike in Lancaster
Pennsylvania talking to a 98 year old
guy and it's one of those amazing
interviews where it's just all it's all
there I have to do anything he's I'm
crying by the end I mean it's just
insane so I go home and I look and I
think well I want to make a shot a
podcast about this and what's amazing
now is I'm not writing this up in print
I'm using this man's own words which
because he's so insanely moving powerful
you know it's just like so much better
that I can hear is voice and so the
question is what does his story need to
be finished not a lot right just a
little bit to put it in context so
there's a case where you stumble across
something and your role your only role
is not to screw it up right don't screw
it up don't bury it just put him out
there tell the story and then just find
some other little element that
makes it clear what to the listener what
it's about it's so that's actually it's
my favorite revisionist history episode
for that reason it's just so pure and
simple when you have let's say in the
case of the outlier chapters or chapter
rather on the Jewish lawyers how do you
capture your notes and organize your
notes on something like that oh what
tools do you use if I mean I just I mean
it's gonna sound so old-school I
transcribe the interview print out the
transcript and underline the parts I
like and then move them into a file and
do you move I what is it a word file how
do you add what type of file is it I
know this is getting very it's a word
file yeah just like move from one word
file to the next word file I don't even
use Google Docs I mean I vaguely
recently got into Google Docs but I sort
of feel like it doesn't really matter I
mean no the the tools I would agree I
mean it's up you know whether it's a pen
or a paintbrush or crayons I think you
still have to know how to use the
writing implement but the process is
interesting to me so if you take these
quotes how what qualifies and this may
seem like a a sort of infantile question
but how do you what qualifies is
interesting yeah no it's not an
infantile question that is in fact the
core question the whole to the extent
that a writer deserves his or her
paycheck it comes down to how good it
they are they hat looking through at
something like looking through a
transcript and understanding what's
interesting right if you can't do that
if you can't kind of get to sort of
visualize what the story is going to
become before it has become anything so
you might be dealing with a document
that is twenty thousand words right
which is or even longer could be thirty
thousand words which is enormous I mean
a book my books are seventy-five
thousand words I mean so you're dealing
with a single interview that might be
you know a third of a book in length and
you have to distill out of that I don't
know
a couple thousand words so you know that
process can take days and I initially go
through and I simply delete all of the
stuff that's clearly that clearly
doesn't belong just that dead space and
then I just take repeated passes pruning
pruning pruning until what I'm left with
is well until I know the interview
almost by heart and then when I'm what
I'm left with is the stuff that matters
if you don't transcribe it yourself it's
so much harder right you really there's
enormous benefits to taking the huge
amount of time necessary to transcribe
it yourself to transcribe resolve and
once you have these nuggets these
various highlights how do you determine
what starts a chapter well or a book for
that matter yeah that's the other thing
that's another thing that kind of
qualifies you as a writer the truth is
that there are so many ways you can do
it there's so many answers to the
problem that I don't get too hung up on
it I sort of think that it's not a math
question where there's only one answer
so as long as you understand there's oh
not just one good answer it takes the
pressure off but typically you know I
might try out several openings I don't
get it so it's made easier by the fact
that I don't start at the beginning so
once you don't start at the beginning
your life just gets so much simpler so
on that point so I have a tendency to
always try the and I think this has
become a bit of a crutch for me because
it seems to work well but I it's become
a bit of a trope if that's the right
word for me where I'm always doing in
media rests right so I'm always taking
some exciting moment right in the middle
of mm X then requires explanation and I
get into that later in the piece but I
found myself doing that effectively all
the time not to turn this into like a
writer doctor consultation but do you
ever find yourself doing that you're
like you know what this recipe works but
I want to play with other recipes or
well that's why I wanted to do a podcast
like this so much which was that with a
podcast you're still storytelling but
suddenly the
the list of considerations is different
it really matters how good your tape is
how powerful the voices are how
meaningful the interaction you have with
the person you're interviewing is so all
those things do you have archival tape
that is credibly powerful so you know
there's a one of the shows is about one
of my favorites of two favorites this is
the other one
it's about giving a sounds boring when I
say that it's about a university
philanthropy and so I can trust
two very wealthy men one who may reach
very different conclusions about where
they want to give their money and one of
the men is my hero and one is my villain
and the hero I'm not gonna add honest to
spoil it but there was a little bit of
tape the hero had just died and the
school that he had given his money to
had a memorial service for him and had
the memorial service a local a cappella
group sang a kind of semi cheesy boyband
song and I've forgotten the title of it
in memoriam of him but in such a way
that it wasn't cheesy anymore it was
actually really touching and so you you
hear this tape and you hear this boy
these acapella group singing the song
and your initial thought is oh my god
and then you're like oh right and you
get it the emotion hits you now if
you're writing about that it's
meaningless
but all that nuance is lost in a podcast
suddenly you're like oh wow
that's my beginning right no question
that's how I that's the way in because
he you want that movement from oh this
is cheesy - oh my god no it's incredibly
meaningful right that's that little
thing so that's what's lovely it's
suddenly I'm after 20 years of doing the
pure print thing I'm shake and I have to
break out of that and think in a
different way about what's powerful you
are a very good public speaker I think
your tremendous speaker how do how do
you plan your keynotes because this is
yet it
from format yeah yeah well if you think
of your most let's say your most
successful and then perhaps a less
successful presentation yeah
how have they how are they different
they differ well there's first of all I
the breakthrough for me and speaking
came when I realized that it required
about 10x more work than I was giving to
it and that was a huge moment so I
decide do I what you realize that
started about uh I was there a
particular incident or so just about
analyze ten years ago when I asked
myself the question do I want to
continue doing this because it has its
pluses and it's minuses and I realized I
only want to continue doing it if I get
much better at it and if I change it in
a way that it's much more meaningful to
me so then I decided I need way more
material I have to give very very
different speeches I can't just give the
same one all the time
I've spent a lot more time thinking
about who I'm speaking to and I have to
spend a lot more time thinking about my
performance and realizing by the way
that it is a performance that it's not
I'm not giving a speech I'm giving a
performance and all of those things I
thought a lot about all of those things
and it took a long time to kind of fully
kind of implement them but it has made
it much more interesting to me I now I
enjoyed in a way I didn't enjoy it when
I was it didn't feel like I was doing it
a kind of halfway manner but I realized
in retrospect I was just because I
hadn't understood I thought that what
giving his speech was was reading an
article and if you think that's what it
is
then you just get up and you read your
article right in its rays once you
actually know it's a world that has its
own rules and principles you're really
acting then it you're like oh wow that's
totally different that it that's I gotta
throw myself into that in a significant
way and so that's what I tried to do is
there anyone in the world of speaking
alive or dead who is the Michael Lewis
for you I once went to a wedding not a
wedding I'm sorry at birthday party for
an old old friend of mine and it was in
in England cuz when I contested my
friend Anne Applebaum and she has all of
these she's been in England for years
and she is all these sort of kind of
fancy English friends who I say fancy
you know not posh but like you know
historians and just kind of like English
intellectuals so she had this birthday
party and this little country house in
the middle of England and the English of
course a way better at giving speeches
and we are first of all but secondly we
were talking about the creme de la creme
of English speech givers like serious
kind of I you know Cambridge and Oxford
debating society kind of people so Neil
Ferguson the historian gave a wedding
toast that is not a birthday toast which
is just the best toast I've ever heard
in my life
I mean it was like so much better than
anything I had ever heard like on
another level I was like oh my god
that's good and part of what made it
genius was he really gave you the
impression he was making it up on the
spot now he might actually have done
that he may be so good he could do that
but he he got out and you just like that
was the the conceit was it I'm just this
is off the cuff I'm just there this is
totally spontaneous and it was so
cleverly done and so hilarious and yet I
think I realized was that it was so
charming that it and what was charming
about it was the ways in which he was
wrong like that the kind of part of the
joke was he was gonna make this
elaborate hilarious argument about Han
who was turning fifty and half the stuff
that he was going to say was not right
it was like me that was sort of like we
did he start off saying that no no he
sort of spun a theory about about the
weekend and about her birthday and about
her friends that was like hilarious
because it was not accurate
no it was like he did it was such
panache and kind of I was just like
first of all that would never have
occurred to me to like make stuff up in
such a dramatic way but also I
can't do the thing I can do
conversational I don't think I ever get
to the level where people think I'm
off-the-cuff like I'm not it's clear
that there's been some effort here but
with him there's just no it was just
like so I ever say I like worship the
guy I just think I think he walks on
water what what are the elements of a
good performance for you what are some
of the ingredients that make a good
performance in York is the thing that I
strive for in speaking is authenticity
which sounds corny but it's really hard
to do when you're giving a prepared talk
to a group of people who belong to a
world that you don't belong to so if I'm
speaking to a group of IT specialists I
don't know anything about IT right
nothing so I'm an outsider and if I'm
trying to say something that will engage
them and be intelligent and make them
think so in the context of doing
something that is artificial by
artificial I don't mean phony I mean in
a sense that I am I have to make an
effort to connect with them it's not I
can't just stand up and talk the way I
would talk to my friends right these
guys belong to a world I don't know or
belong to so I'm doing something that
requires an effort but at the same time
it has to feel like me right they have
to feel like they are connecting with me
and that I'm not I can't feel like I'm
faking it all right it's kind of so
that's that's hard and that's an really
but it's hard in a good way it's really
that's what makes it interesting so the
question I have I ask myself is I would
like to say something intelligent about
IT while still remaining true to myself
someone who knows very little about IT
right so this that and if you pull it
off that's interesting to the audience
so they get that they don't they're not
bringing me in because I'm an IT
specialists but they do they want what
would bring that what makes them what
satisfies them is my attempt to speak to
them while being true to myself right my
attempt to bridge the can i bridge the
gap is the question really that they're
asking them
in the back of the mind and when you can
bridge the gap that's really satisfying
to someone it's like oh right that's you
know that I think you you know you've
succeeded when you have just a few more
questions about writing because I'm up
most likely about to go into as we
discussed briefly crunch writing
deadlines myself when you have for
instance one or two stories for a book
and you understand what the theme is
going to be or some of the the
structural components how do you find
the others or is it a case where you've
gathered these stories over the span of
a time with the inkling of an idea and
then you have half of it locked and
loaded already well there's a good
action example of this from revisionist
history from this podcast I started out
by wanting I wanted to tell a story
about this kid who I had met who was a
teenager and lived in LA came from a
poor family and had I don't know what
his IQ is 150 I'm he's a
one-in-a-million kid I thought his story
of how does that what happens to you if
you're you have an IQ of 150 and you
grew up in South Central right but
that's sort of interesting so I was
going to tell that story and so I talked
to the kid and I was particularly
interested in how does he get to college
is it easy do you get recognized is it
like you're a great 15 year old
basketball player and they they find
they always find you if you if you can
dunk a basketball and hit a 3-point shot
and you're you could dominate your you
know middle school basketball team and
you live in Nebraska they find you right
so my question was is that what it's
like if you got an IQ of 115 you live in
South Central did I just find you and
like adopt you and blue so I was I went
out I had this long conversation with
this kid it's credibly powerful totally
interesting and then as I tell the story
I realized oh so my episodes are 45
minutes and I realized this story is all
I need
United he's he's the whole thing I mean
I can do little contact contextual
things but there's no room for anything
else here not just room logistically or
physically there's no emotional room for
anything else right this kid isn't tall
you're in tears by the I mean he's I
want to happen to him and his story is
crazy and then this is an other kid we
talk about it's like you can't so then I
said oh so there's other things I wanted
to say so I thought I'd do another show
also on the same topic of what happens
how good are we at finding at fulfilling
the American Dream the American promise
which is if you work hard and you have
some ability you can make your way up
the ladder that's really what so this
part of revisionist history is Revati is
revisiting that promise that we make how
good are we at fulfilling it so into a
second show which is all about do
college is actually how do they find
these kids do they do a good job of
finding how do they find them what do
they do spend a lot of time and money on
it today and the answer is the college
is - a terrible job of finding them so
that's is well why so I do the show on
why why did I do a terrible job and the
answer is a lot of time they're
distracted but more than that they're
spending their money somewhere else it
takes money to find these kids not just
to find them if the cost of educating a
kid is 50 grand and you want to bring in
a kid from South Central
he doesn't have 50 grand so you got to
pay 50 grand you could you're out 50
grand if you want to bring them to your
school so if you got to spend 50 grand
on him it's 50 grand you can't spend on
something else right that starts to get
really interesting all right so what's
the thing you can't spend on and if you
can't spend on that other thing how do
you compete with other colleges that do
spend on the other thing right so that's
what the whole episodes about so then I
do that when I'm like I do that one like
wait a minute I'm not done this gets
more interesting right so if you have to
spend you've got to find the 50 grand
then where do you get the 50 grand so
now we get into philanthropy that's why
I did this whole thing on philanthropy
so that was the third one so then so
these are all stories that grow out of
you mean
you find it all starts with one kid I
find the kid and all of a sudden
up with three very different stories all
of which look at the problem of the kid
from a different angle and that's very
typical of the way books work for me
which is you start with the nugget and
then you just start walking around it
and parts of it just kind of you're like
oh that deserves its own you know that's
that's a you know it's like when you the
thing I find myself doing when I
interview someone most often is stopping
them say we I think when I transcribe it
tapes I hear that so many times wait
wait stop and then I make them go back
and elaborate on that point which was
like that kind of weird point wait is
that you know they skip over because
it's old hat to them and you were like
no no no that I could spend hours on
that point you know so it's all I do
I know exactly Olivia and it did strikes
me that you asked questions as part of
that walking around the first story
right and you asked a question that then
redirects you or focuses you in into
another topic you find a story then you
ask another question which then leads to
in this case another episode but it
could have been another chapter of a
book yeah if you were to credit someone
or some people or resources with helping
you to get better at asking questions
who or what would that be my dad is a
great question as Oscar and my father
has this I've spoken about it many times
he has of his many gifts one in
particular as a kid always had the
biggest impact on on me which is my
father has zero intellectual
insecurities so this is the only thing
he has in common with Obama you know
Ballmer the same way but but has no it
has never crossed his mind to be
concerned that the world thinks he's an
idiot just isn't he's not in that game
right so if he doesn't understand
something he just asks you he doesn't
care if he sounds foolish he will ask
the most obvious question like you know
and it was without any sort of
concern about it maybe it's because he's
my dad's a mathematician so he has his
thing
that he knows it's he's really good at
and so he's like he's home free I think
if you have a PhD math you're home free
you're home free well if you need
something you the true or its false or
it's clear it's not yeah and it's like
you're not if you look like an idiot
because you don't know anything about
basketball who cares right so he he asks
lots and lots and lots of dumb quest
I mean dumb in the best sense of that
word dumb questions wait but he'll say
to someone I don't understand explain
that to me
or he'll and he'll just keep asking
questions until he he gets it right and
I grew up listening to him do this in
every conceivable setting you know my
father made friends so my father who's
this guy with this PhD in man he made
friends with all of these farmers who
were our neighbors who were all dropouts
it was in Canada in Canada they were all
do when they basically maybe seventh
grade and he first of all treated them
with like equals and secondly was
intensely interested in what they knew
that he didn't know and would ask them
tons and tons of questions about why
they did what they did so that's what I
grew up around right that and that's
what I do
I mean it's there's no it's straight
from my dad I don't think there's any I
just do and I you know what I'm hanging
out with my father and someone
interesting we do the same thing we just
start asking questions it's our sort of
thing well it strikes me also that the
the dumb questions or the obvious
questions are precisely the questions
oftentimes we should be asking because
half the people in the room if it's in a
group setting or probably thinking of
those questions anyway but are
embarrassed for whatever reason to bring
them up it's sweet example this I often
imagine my dad meeting Bernie Madoff my
father would say he would look at the
returns and he would say wow that's
really good because as a mathematician
he would know that you know these steady
whatever it was nine percent a year
you're in you're out you know that's
really and then you would say how did
you do that and then may not had that
remember that stark explanation that
didn't that was [ __ ] and my father
would just simply continue to ask really
really dumb obvious questions and until
Madoff would either have had
leave or because he would have tried his
patience and been at risk of but he
would never have invested money with it
because he would have said I don't
understand a hundred times right I don't
understand how that works I read it like
in this kind of dumb kind of you know
slow voice I don't understand sir you
know you know what is going on okay so
let me ask a and you feel free to not
did not answer this if you don't want
but so I I ask a lot of questions I
enjoy asking a lot of questions and it
can drive some people crazy yeah uh did
your mom get the 20 questions about a
lot of things or was the relationship
different oh she asked lots of questions
too I they are neither of them she's not
intellectually insecure either they're
not um it wasn't directed at my mother
it was directed the outside world they
had a bit they have an exceedingly
harmonious relationship they don't
yeah they don't they don't do that
that's it's all it's reserved for
outsiders really what - what would you
attribute the the harmony is there a lot
of non harmonious unharmonious
relationships in the world there I mean
they were lucky to be well suited there
also but both in Crete Inc incredibly um
they're very calm people so there's very
very few they have very little conflict
because it doesn't they defuse conflict
really well I think I think it probably
would be a good way of saying is they
can speak rationally and yeah they're
not interested in they know I've never
seen them pick a fight with each other
for example that doesn't interest so I
have so many questions that I want to
ask you I'm just going to jump into a
rather uncoated list of miscellanea
gonna try some new ones this time around
what is the best or most worthwhile
investment you've ever made
could be money time energy or otherwise
or just a very good investment it's a
really interesting question all of the
investment said the most worthwhile
investments or investments about time
they have to do with time and they're
all about persevering past point that I
would normally have quit so I can think
for example of books where there's no
payoff didn't come until page a thousand
and yet it was very getting to that page
was incredibly important in some future
endeavor or when I was describing how I
ran across that transcript of that
school shooter which that was about an
investment of time where I mean I was
sort of screwing around now swing around
on word I wasn't looking for much longer
than I would normally look I kind of for
reasons I don't really understand put my
impatience aside and and committed a
much longer period of time to that hunt
so those are I would say those are
probably that it's a very broad category
but those are the best investments know
when you said page a thousand you
thought you're talking about reading
yeah but I mean in any kind of generally
speaking hunting so many of the really
wonderful things that I've uncovered in
my life not just from my writing but
also personally have come after
elongated hunts so you never find the
thing that is moving moving and powerful
in the first five minutes just doesn't
happen I remember a friend of mine who I
didn't really feel very friendly towards
when he said this said to me when I was
90% done with my second book for our
body I said wow well you know pretty
close to the finish line 90% done he
goes oh congratulations only a 50% left
and so heard that from a lot of
long-distance runners also you know like
I know the race starts at Mile 20 or
whatever it might be yeah I going back
to the sort of investments and these not
postponed but like delayed gratification
wins like this page of thousand can you
think of any failures that set you up
for later success or a favorite failure
of yours yeah I mean I mean it's all
kinds I when I was a kid I was
in just one of many but I was a runner
very serious runner and I like what
distance 1500 meters and in our meters
and I were puking distances yes and I I
in my third year of running seriously
lost races I thought I was going to win
a kind of what for me they that age was
a quite quite a drum at a trauma
fashion and I quit running and it it was
the first I would regard that as the of
that the first real failure of my life
something I really wanted to do a lot I
didn't and I feel like it was hugely
important both because it maybe think
hard about what my priorities were what
that I had placed running too high in
that list but more than that it it um I
lived then later in life went back and
thought a lot about why I quit and was
dissatisfied with my reasons so anything
you can this whole notion of circling
back I think is so important I mean it's
this shows God revisionist history so
it's explicitly about that but you know
I I would almost obsessively revisit my
reasons for quitting running and
scrutinized them and say was right what
did I learn in the intervening 5 10 15
20 years about Who I am what I want what
it takes to be good at something so that
was a very valuable a really valuable
experience
um at exactly the right time because
that's the age where you know where
decisions
I'm not decisions matter but where I
think you reflect on things in your
adolescence in a way that you don't
reflect on things later in your life
what would age was lists are were great
I was 15 15 I always thought I was going
to go back at some point and be a 9th
grade teacher so right around that like
14 to 16 range it seems like there are a
lot of very important Forks in the road
yeah I think there is I think you are
because so much is everything is plastic
at that age right so you can mold it
whatever way you want
um and so it's just a kind of like I
think about why how confusing and
complicated those years are in
retrospect what is give any morning
routines
what is the first 60 minutes of your day
look like could be any day of the week
let's just say it's a workday I will I
was just saying earlier I try I think
one should eat very little in the
morning so at what time do you wake up
did we know eight I have a big thing of
tea what type of tea sir I'm gonna keep
lapsang souchong oh well that's great
stuff great stuff if you like what is it
I remember friend who's getting off of
he loved whiskey and he felt like the
smell reminded him of some type of PD
alcoholic beverage so yeah yeah it has
an amazing smell it's a very
controversial tea and then I might I'm
going to pull a Malcolm here wait wait
wait why is it a controversial tea it
some people smell it and they just run
in the opposite direction they think it
is it there they don't even think it's
tea and I've never seen people have such
a kind of business there's a little
coffee shop where I go often in the
morning to have bitee and they have it I
I think I'm one of the only people who
order it I think they get it because of
me and it's like I walk in there like
you know make a beeline for it but it's
clear that you know I'm in a distinct
minority it smells I mean you can smell
it from quite a ways off I might eat a
little bit of oatmeal that's pretty much
all Olly the moment you go to one of
your go twos yeah but not a lot and then
I look at three websites I guess we're
going like three hours so not a lot
means like a cupful a couple spoons I
got a cup full of africa tsamina just
enough to them you know have a
reasonable something in my stomach and
then I will look at three websites the
first one is let's run calm the nerdy
runners all serious runners read let's
run then I read marginal revolution
Taylor Cohen's column and then I read
espn.com just to make sure nothing major
happened in sports and then I start my
work how do you end what time is that
than when you're starting your work so
we're talking where now we're still
before nine and then if I have riding to
do its best to do it in the next the two
hours of follow so before lunch yeah and
what is your routine look like is there
in those few hours when you start your
work what does that look like is there
particular music he's in a coffee shop
sitting in a coffee shop I'm uh or you
know some restaurant I'm not at home and
I'm not on office and I'm working pretty
steadily I'm not really easily
distractible been around 11:30 or so I
kind of have to do other things I mean I
I don't stop working but I stopped
writing do you listen to music when you
write do you just take in the ambient
music on and I write almost entirely in
public places so whatever I don't listen
to music myself a headphone but I like
the noise because I I came of age in a
newsroom so I need that I mean I you
know I learned how to write in the
middle of when newsrooms are not noisy
now they used to be credibly loud so
that's what I need to kind of get going
and then do you is that when the bulk of
your writing is done is that pre-lunch
period or do you write in the afternoon
so we really write in the afternoon if I
find ya journalists seem to be very
adaptable for former journalists people
have worked in newspapers or had those
types of daily deadlines
yeah we're faster and also remember
writing is not the time consuming part
it's knowing what to write it's the
thinking and the arranging and the
interviewing and the researching and the
organizing and the that's what takes
time you know writing this blissful I
wish I could do it more I mean it's it's
a break from all of the hassle so let's
just say end of workday to bed what are
your winddown routines look like we're
running at probably after at the end of
the afternoon
and although I'm injured now but that's
really the highlight of the day of the
kind of workday some days I'll go to my
train with my Track Club them to go for
a long run or I'll go biking or I'll go
to a CrossFit workout or something
physical okay what is your favorite
movement and CrossFit or exercise and
least well I kind of runners you know
secretly disdain any activity that's not
run so i guys i know the first right so
I don't I don't I don't even want to
think about favorite in that context
it's something I suffer through because
it's necessary to ward off injury and
when it's over I'm very happy but uh you
know I'm much happier if I can go and
you know run eight miles with some
friends got a pre-bid anything in
particular no I'll eat dinner might read
an evening i watch sports or tea you
have trouble getting to sleep who do you
generally sleep easily i man i come from
a family of we are champion sleepers
Gladwell's are some are some of the best
sleepers out there there we are some of
the best it is our it is our defining
characteristic that we're at our
definition of a bad night of sleep is so
hilarious because it's like you know my
father will say he had trouble sleeping
what that means is he was up for 20
minutes between you know for and for 20
I mean that's a bad night of sleep so if
the Gladwell's are heading up the
leaderboard and sleep uh we're really
good what do you guys not gonna we are
or you personal what are we not good at
we're what do you find challenging um
well we're not great talkers we're all
pretty introverted with the exception of
my brother it makes up for it we are not
we're not terribly adventurous I don't I
mean we're adventures in certain very
very specific ways but we don't I didn't
grow up going we would go on family
vacations to either England or Jamaica
where my both my parents are from my
father was to travel a lot to
interesting places but we never went out
to eat or went to the movies or went to
concerts or the sort of going out thing
was not something we did we were we
would I would go into our summers when I
basically never left the house you know
so we're we were not um we didn't civics
were we didn't explore the our immediate
surroundings in a way that we might have
I what is some of the or an example of
the worst advice that you hear being
dispensed or given could be could be
related to anything writing running this
yeah the worst advice that in general we
give in America is that we terrify high
school kids about their college choices
in all all things related to college
fall into the category of bad advice as
you will find out when you listen to my
rants about collagen on this podcast I
think the American college system needs
to be blown up and they need to start
over
I mean it's to my mind you could not
have conceived of a worse system so you
know anything any advice that has to do
with you need to work out and get into
the best college you can it's just I'm
sorry it's just [ __ ] I mean it is
just terrible you should not try to go
to the best college you can because
particularly if best is defined by US
News and World Report you should go to a
place that what college should the sole
test of what a good college is is is it
a place where I find myself late at
night having deeply interesting
conversations with people that I like
and find interesting if you you go where
you can do that right that's all that
matters so am I so inspired by what I
learned during the day that I want to be
talking about it at 1:00 in the morning
and do I have someone who will have that
conversation with me and will challenge
me that's it that's it everything else
is nonsense right so you tell me what
that place is now is so that place could
be any number of a thousand places in
the world maybe you maybe even that
place is unpredictable maybe it is that
what matters is not that some schools
can provide that experience in some kid
what matters is what happens when I go
to that school do I create that
experience for myself and I think that
experience could be created at almost
any institution in the country right now
there are interesting kids everywhere
and it's only in our snobbery that we
have decided that interestingness is
defined by your test scores this is just
such it's so she's not
just a lie right Tesco is sure they
matter and someday but I'm talking about
college now what makes for a powerful
college experience is can I find someone
interesting to have an interesting
discussion with and that you can do you
can do that if you are curious and
you're interesting that's it oh you are
by the way not that you're interesting
your interest did interested right
that's all that matters
she comes back to the questions and
having having the ability yeah and I am
Oh to ask good questions and follow-up
questions only some of the people that
you learn most from in those settings
are some of the most flawed people right
people it's not true that you learn the
most from the smartest most put together
people you've I think college experience
it's people who had a lasting impact on
me were deeply deeply flawed people and
their flaws were what almost drew them
to me drew me to them and what I kind of
fixated on and found fascinating
I had a friend still one of my very best
friends end up being very very
successful in college she was a basket
case complete basket case to the point
where he was he literally said this to
me once I said why do you have a library
book that's three months overdue you're
fine is going up every day he said well
I'm afraid to take it back because I
can't afford the fine he said this dude
this is a guy and that fast that you
know that kind of and yet simultaneously
he was I actually turned out to be a
brilliant student or brilliant
professional and just the squaring those
two sides to his personality the idea
that he was hapless in some really
crucial respects and yet made an
incredibly successful place for himself
in the world figuring that contradiction
out took yours and when I did kind of
figured out it so enhanced my
understanding of people in the world and
just of understanding the ways in which
he compensated for his hapless nespresso
realizing that
it doesn't if your hapless in that kind
of logistical sense common sense since
here's no common sense if you can if you
if you're thoughtful about it it won't
matter one iota what flaws or weaknesses
do you have that have turned out to be
strengths in some capacity this is like
a job interview question isn't it
I was going to offer you a position to
embarrass enterprises but I think you're
dizzy well probably uh God uh my uh it's
only a job interview say sometimes I
just work too hard
exactly well in in in in dealing with my
own impatience and my sloppiness uh into
attending to those flaws I think I have
done that's been a really crucial thing
in in helping me achieve what I've
achieved so it's just could you
elaborate on that yeah I mean I'm sloppy
how are you it was anyway what in what
sense you know I don't slop in a hurry
like clothes all over the floors no no
sloppy about I'm in a hurry
uh I you know I don't always
double-check something I know or I I'll
interview someone for forty-five minutes
when I should in you of them for two
hours or you know I'm just kind of like
I'm a good enough person I'm not a
perfectionist like five is fine let's do
and so I become so aware of that now
that I've compensated and I have taught
myself to be a lot more of a
perfectionist or have forced myself to
keep asking questions much longer than I
would have when I said earlier that it
was these investments of time that have
been so that's what I'm talking about
that I forced myself to invest more time
in a lot of activities knowing that if I
did it my normal way I'd be out the door
yeah right
you know I'd be thinking about what I
wanted for dinner as opposed to so
that's sort of a
a very it's why I buy by the way I so
object to so when you when you observe
or measure someone's natural
inclinations you haven't got a picture
of them because you don't know what they
do with those natural inclinations right
so it turns out that one of the most
important things about me is that how
obsessed I am with those two flaws of
mine right so identifying those as my
natural inclinations tells you exactly
the opposite about me because you're
compensating because I developing the
opposite I am massively compensating for
them all day long
right it's obsessed with calm saying
have you received a lot of bad advice
along the way as to what you might do
professionally or has that not been the
case no I mean I don't I'm not an advice
seeker about those kinds of things nor
much of an advice giver so I haven't
really gotten a lot of and also my
position is you can't know I kind of
stumbled into most things I've been
doing
I must refer to simply to be open to
opportunity then to plan my path I think
that's a better for me anyway I don't
know I mean people are different so some
people need to plan but I'm not up I
don't think I had really am but all you
know that your comment about the
compensation and just that that last
mile so to speak with the interviews and
so on reminds me of Laird Hamilton they
surfer and the face he gave he was
trying to teach me a lot of patience at
a surf at one point a few years ago and
he said when you think you've caught a
wave paddle again he's like because if
you don't it's like that last paddle and
you think you're there you're just not
going to catch the wave yeah when you
think of the word successful who is the
first person who comes to mind and why
well you know I'm so deeply obsessed
with running these days that I
immediately think of runners that's fine
there's an American runner Galen Rupp
who's maybe our Summa medalist in the
London Games in the 10,000 and I really
admire him for many reasons he's first
of all a very he's a system runner
that's to say he was sort of
identified in high school as being
someone who promised he's been with the
same coach ever since and he had if a
thoughtful training path and career path
what was his name Ian Galen Rupp
he's a very also a very beautiful runner
both those things matter to me makes a
beautiful runner is if you look him up
on the internet yeah you looked at the
way he moved you would say he's like a
ballet dancer he just has grace you know
they're ugly runners they're beautiful
ones he's a beautiful runner those two
things in combination the idea that he
is set on an aesthetic level is deeply
pleasing so he does the thing that he
wants to do not just successfully by the
standard metric he runs very quickly he
wins races but also by an appear Li
irrelevant aesthetic metric he's beauty
he creates beauty as he's doing it but
that matters to me and it matters to me
that he's so thoughtful purposeful in
his to use that overused phrase in his
preparation know that it's not
happenstance or that he sort of thought
about what does it mean from for me Gail
and Rob to be to bring out the best in
myself and you know running is tricky
because you running is all about
restraint even especially at the elite
level you can't be obsessive or a
perfectionist and succeed as a runner
you'll get injured running is all about
good enough because you will have too
much training volume yeah you can't the
minute you you're walking this fine line
between adequately preparing yourself
for racing and overtraining which leads
to injury and burnout all these kinds of
things and the whole struggle in running
is to not get injured to not cross that
line and so in order to not cross that
line you have to reign in all of these
tendencies your obsessiveness you want
to do the tenth you know repetition
you're doing ten times up whatever half
miles and you know logically that after
nine that that's enough you've pushed
your body as far as you can go but
you're you know you're kind of anal
discipline self says no do 10 because 10
was the workout right
do 10 you have to be tough enough to say
no no I've done enough for the day and
walk away right do you know how hard
that is simply for the kinds of
personalities who are attracted to elite
running I mean it's insane right so that
kind of that notion of how hard it is to
say it's good enough and walk away it's
like he does that well so a couple of
things it makes me think about a story I
heard related to Charlie Francis very
controversial a straight sprint coach
and Johnson and so on the reality is he
was a brilliant coach brilliant cook and
I hate to say it but I'm not going to
point fingers at any specific people but
very likely that all of the top
sprinters at that level are using
something besides were spirulina I'm
sure it's still true but go on in that
year I and Charlie Francis is here
absolutely yeah Bobby that was kind of
the Golden Age of doping in a sense but
the athletes always have more resources
than the the water crew in terms of
testing in that cat mass game but some
really interesting things that have come
out I mean just recently give an example
sorry so there was a period of time
where the vast majority of world
championship or Olympic sprinters had
prescriptions due to their narcolepsy
because they won big modafinil as a
stimulant yeah pre-race but I digress
but what Charlie said was in the case of
an elite sprinter some said how do you
push your athletes and he said no no the
last thing I need to do is push my
athletes it's my job to rein them in I
always have to rein them in and he would
have to say no Charlie you can't do two
sets of squats with six hundred pounds
on your back and 160 or whatever it was
you have to do one set and and so on but
the I wanted to come back to plan so you
said you're not much for plans but you
are one for systems
all right so made me think it seems at
least in the case of running made me
think of and I'm going to paraphrase
here there's a quote from I want to say
Jeff Bezos something along the lines of
we're uncompromising on the vision and
flexible on the details yeah where do
you have systems in your life that you
rely on
I wish I had more systems sometimes I
don't really have a lot of I mean I've
sort of because I now I'm essentially
self-employed and don't go I mean I have
discipline personal discipline but it's
not is it that rigid I don't know if I
have part of the reason I'm said I think
Galen Rupp is successful is because I'm
a little bit envious of the system and
structure that he has in place and screw
to me that how much can be achieved when
you're that kind of thoughtful about
what you're doing I mean nothing as
someone you know is obsessed with sports
as I am the thing that always breaks
your heart
is that someone who leaves potential on
the table like I don't think Galen Rupp
has and that is an extraordinary
achievement but to be able to say when
he retires I ran as fast as I could
possibly have run that is more important
than to say I want to go metal or I set
a world record or but I don't mean any
kind of cheesy I mean that really I
really mean that to say I got a 99
percent of my ability in the Iuh and I
think folks should be surprised and
you've probably interacted with many
more elite runners and I have but I've
met people a few of them and I've also
interacted with coaches and first since
physical therapists who've worked with
people like Jackie joyner-kersee hot and
it's very common that they would say
about that level of athlete I just can't
get them they've never let it all go and
really given a hundred percent because
whether it's fear of a hamstring tear
fear of ex fear of y'see never might be
so the fact that this yeah this Runner
is anything else to being it all on the
track yeah so it's just you know we've
been talking there's two necessarily
contradictory things here with runners
which is training is about restraint but
racing is not right so that that's why
we're so getting out why the psychology
of these elite athletes is so complex
restraint restrain restrain in
preparation get in the track all of a
sudden no no more restraint go all that
behavior on you've been conditioned
ignore all that really hard to kind of
and you know I as I returned to running
quite recently in running in a serious
way and that's the piece of it that is
proving really hard for me to grasp is
that idea of turning it on on race day
so I trained very well and I race less
well and for that very reason
whereas I look around me you know really
elite runners the distance difference
between their training and racing is
astounding like they're just different
different animals I mean it's it's
fascinating to see that what books
besides your own have you gifted to
other people the most I am there's one
book I've given the most in my life
which is a book called
mother several now I think about it
there's a book by um Timothy Wilson
called strangers to ourselves which is
one of the loveliest most insightful
books about social psychology that I
ever read and I give that a lot to
people and I give every time I meet and
weirdly I'm always meeting people who
work in retail particularly like I
always send them particularly Jewish I
send them a book called the merchant
Prince's the merchant Prince um she's
it's a book about the great Jewish
retail families of America so in the
19th century all these people come over
from Europe who have have experience in
the garment trader retailing and all of
the not all of them but an extraordinary
number of the early 20th century late
19th century department stores that pop
up around America are founded by Jewish
immigrants from Europe right you you
know from you know I mean you literally
you go to any town in America that the
traditional department store is one one
of those families well a guy and I
forgotten his name wrote a book about
those families is called the merchant
princes and it's all princess Prince's
plural okay yes it's fantastic as a kind
of it's about everything I'm interested
in it's about immigrants it's about
people
figuring out and then conquering an
unfamiliar marketplace right it's about
all of the brilliant ideas that were
that came to these guys in as they as
they invented the department store right
the ideas of bottling we're still you
know all these internet retailers
there's they're just grandchildren of
these guys I mean there's nothing
nothing dramatically new has happened
they worked it all out 100 years ago I
mean it really humbles you about the
so-called retail revolution of the last
ten years and there's such extraordinary
characters and I love the way their
personality is kind of imprinted on
there under business so there's a
fantastic chapter about Filene's Filene
brothers who start Filene's in boston
which they have Filene's basement and so
on yeah and they invent these they have
incredibly interesting ideas about how
to hold a sale how to generate how to
use people's kind of psychological
impulses to generate the desire to buy
these guys are so far I had everybody
else it's night you know it's like a
hundred years ago and they are on
another level right just like it is that
it's one sort like that I've done it's a
brilliant book do you read any fiction
Oh huge maths I read uh I read um spying
spy novels spy novels yeah if it has the
word spy in it I've read it Annie so for
someone who's unfamiliar with the genre
but excited to get started where should
they start well I mean did we have how
many hours do we have but we should if
you know nothing about it you should
start with John Licari of course and
read his first five books so I would
read through at least through Tinker
Tailor Soldier Spy and you can keep
going actually no no read you should be
little drums too a little drummers girl
or even Russia house I liked his later
stuff less cell but it's still fantastic
but you must read spy came in from the
cold I mean that's just kind of like
goes to given yeah um and then uh I mean
I read all of the child books or not spy
through those per se but they're
thrillers
that those are fantastic I mean I have
hundreds I have literally hundreds of
spinal spy novels in my in my house what
$100 or less purchased I mean this is
ballpark right meaning just not a
Bugatti or something yeah that is most
positively impacted your life that comes
to mind probably a piece of music I
think it was probably an album by Brian
Eno called another green world which is
one of his earlier early 70s I think
it's ambient music but not not the kind
of really weird ambient music there's an
adage that says the music you discover
when you are 18
I think it's 18 is the magic here is the
music that stays with you for the rest
of your life well I discovered that when
I was 18 and I I sing the songs that
album in my head all the time and um I
worship Brian Eno um he's a fascinating
guy you have you interviewed him I
haven't I would enjoy it though I helped
my god he's I have a collection of cards
that he also put out called oblique
strategies yes I know of all that does
yeah and of it right on top of there's
another one called the wack pack which
is a series of odd questions just
intended to help you it's genius yet
he's also the most articulate person
I've ever met
Wow you he's douche I should I should
try to get a mystery no on the podcast
you should oh you should because just to
listen to him talk it's distracting how
perfectly he talks so you're he's one of
those you just want to listen because
it's perfectly done paragraphs and
register complication it's just yeah II
just I mean it's I can't explain the
experience it's just kind of inspiring
sounds like I've had that experience
when watching Neil Gaiman speak or
listening to him speak I also perform
just incredible what is something you
believe that other people think is crazy
or something that a lot of people
believe that you think is crazy aside
from a college piece either either one
but most interested in things that you
believe that other people would raise an
eyebrow think that believe in ghosts
I like this alright tell me more I just
do I don't understand my aunt who lives
in Jamaica
uess live in his house called hilton
hill which was said to be haunted it was
a particular room that was said to be
haunted and so I slept in a room as a
kid like 13 14 it was haunted saw ghosts
in there played the guitar in real the
night I don't know and I that age I was
like Jamaica everyone blues and ghosts
not everyone but it's a cono you people
believe in ghosts so do I think the
house is haunted i Shi do think it's
haunted and also don't understand if you
believe in God as I do it's not that
hard to believe in ghosts I mean so I
believe in the existence of things
outside my own direct physical
experience right so and also I don't
think that why that why that's
controversial like why people think that
you can only believe in things that you
have we have conventional explanations
for and that you can see and touch
well that strikes me as being why would
you limit yourself like that I mean I'm
not crazy I don't believe in UFOs
although I don't rule them out I mean I
don't I'm not a kind of spiritualist but
it in a kind of purely rational way I
believe there's stuff out there that
can't be properly explained why because
why would we have explanations for every
we're not yet right I mean there are
it's just just because there's a ways to
go there a phenomena that we can't
currently explain or examine using the
scientific method right which is
sometimes poorly sometimes properly
implemented doesn't mean we won't and
there's I mean you just have to sort of
look back in the history books to see
many many many examples of this yeah if
you're my mother is an identical twin
and if you know an identical twin you
witness that they live thousands of one
lives in Jamaica one is mechana de you
know and they do that thing that twins
do which is they call each other and say
I was so worried about you and then the
other one will say I just had some kind
of accident or one will say welcome to
the middle of night with a terrible pain
in my stomach mm I was like that's
because I just had an upper
for today you know like that kind of
stuff which is like that weird thing you
get about in it happens I don't know
this is the second time this has come up
on this podcast I had an identical twin
on my podcast we talked about yeah it's
like so do I have a rational explanation
for that does my mother know does it is
it may be a coincidence I don't know
maybe I I mean I don't know just needs
explanation I don't have one but I'm
open to things that don't add
explanation so I the question the what
is something you believe that other
people think is insane is I actually
modified kind of paraphrased wording of
a question that Peter teal likes to ask
I suppose when he's interviewing
founders what is your what are your what
is your opinion of Peter teal if you
have one well all I know about him is
what I know from this whole Gawker thing
I know that he's having bad odor among
some people um and I never read his book
but I think I think he said he might
have taken a shot at me I don't remember
this so the zr1
he he takes issue with what he how he
interprets your position as it relates
to success and circumstantial factors or
a lotta does he think there's more he's
more up to the individual that would be
his position I see as a reasonable
position I mean the the irony in pardon
one of my fans pointed this out is that
he talks in the very beginning of the
book how failing to get a sort of fact
by a string of events outside of his
control failing to get a clerkship led
to all these other things that wouldn't
have happened had he received the
clerkship but there we go
are there any uh I'm going to word this
broadly innovators and that's sort of
jumping I live in Silicon Valley so a
lot of real innovators and even more
people who like to fashion themselves
innovators are there any people do you
think are engaged in very interesting
innovation at the moment oh wow
I mean so many obviously so many people
and most people doing the interesting
stuff we wouldn't even know about would
we I mean they wouldn't have told us so
I don't have publicists yeah they're I
don't know if I have a good answer to
that I mean I'm sort of continually we
could also take a retrospective I mean
because like everything that was old is
once new again right yeah they
interviewed the retail so there are
other examples of innovators that have
had a that that you've become fascinated
by for instance I interviewed Marc
Andreessen recently incredible tech icon
fascinating guy and he looks to people
like Walt Disney and Edison you apply
lessons that they learned and habits
they developed rules they developed for
themselves - yeah I guess I would say my
New Yorker colleague Atul Gawande has
done all this work um with checklists so
get such great stuff fantastic stuff and
I I really admired him because it's
deeply unpopular work within his own
profession but it's work that has I mean
extraordinary potential for saving lives
and particularly it's one of those
things that ultimately I think PI's far
more usefulness in developing world and
the developed world I mean the Lion
infection example in the checklist
manifesto is just it's just staggering I
mean the area but you took a
extraordinary risk to his own reputation
in domestically in America and the
medical profession by doing that people
doctors do not like checklists and they
think of him as simplifying dumbing down
with all they have all incentive
epithets they use against him unfairly I
think because he's not saying all
medicine can be reduced to a checklist
he's saying let's find the parts that
can be and do it that way right
so I admire the idea but almost more I
admire the kind of guts that made the
idea possible I have so their number of
books about 20 or 30 that I have in my
living room because I spent a lot of
time there right
often times although I do like to get
out to a third location of some sense
guys I'll go stir-crazy but I have a
it's about ten books that are face out
to remind me of certain things or to
elicit certain emotions and the
checklist manifesto is one of them oh
yeah please do
the other thing by the way tons and tons
of people write interesting things a
tool then went and put his ideas into
action on a grand scale throughout the
world I mean taught follow through so
he's not this kind of intellectual
holding forth he has the idea he takes
the heat and then he makes it happen in
a real way around the world I mean it's
extraordinary varied an animal what
advice would you give to your actually
before we get to that one we talked
about books do any favorite movies or
documentaries that you've seen multiple
times no I'm not really a movie or
Darwin tree bang alright well then
that's an easy easy pass to the advice
you would give you thirty year-old self
I would have left North America leave
North America to get out of there get
out why because you'll wake up when
you're 50 and realize that you spent
your entire working career in North
America which is despite the fact that
it pretends to be the only place that
matters is not the in place that matters
I just would have been I would have been
so much more interesting and thoughtful
and would insightful and whatever if I
had experience particularly in the
developing world I had an idea when I
was in my 20s that I wanted to go and
study in Jamaica you know a place where
I have family and I have some
familiarity with it I should have done
it or some similar kind of thing no I
just think and I it's always my advice
to young people which is particularly
young people of privilege is just leave
I mean go away you can come back but you
have to you can't stay in the cocoon
your whole life Yeah right your it will
limit you in ways you cannot even begin
to understand at this point totally
agree I was chatting with Sebastian
Junger
about that she got out of the bubble
yeah yeah how badly about the system and
also any potential remedies and he felt
a mandatory year of
in his case national service but it
could be volunteering with the Peace
Corps and after I think it was high
school and spending a year exposing
yourself to those types of environments
before going into the real world
somewhere in yeah this case North
America - two of the religious groups
who take a lot of heat but for which I
for whom I have enormous respect the
Mennonites in the Mormons have an
institutionalized practice of sending
people to other cultures their mission
the mission and that's I just you know
people who go on those missions come
back transformed not just spiritually
but you know they have seen the side of
the other end it by the way they're not
going as American college students do
when they do the year abroad to Florence
Florence does not going to Florence does
not expand your horizons don't do it
your abroad in Paris like this is that
notion that oh I you know my school I'm
gonna break out of the box and go and
spend you know six months in this in the
seventh or on two small you know that
[ __ ] go somewhere real right that's
the that's what the that's the upside of
that kind of experience when people have
the means I mean I I spent a year in
Japan as an exchange student at fifteen
my first real time outside of the United
States and completely rocked my world
it's just called everything into
question and I so when people have the
Chancellor think about going here here
here and if Japan's on list I go I
always respond with go to Japan because
it will make no sense you won't be able
to read anything and the English that
you do read won't make any sense people
do not speak English well and you should
just walk until you get lost and then
trying to find your way back because
it's safe you won't get hurt and amazing
but I went there for the first time
months ago
oh really blew my mind that means like
oh my god so interesting Oh
any any favorite moments or frames there
so briefly I had to come back sad
because I was working on this podcast
but uh I was there for like four days I
just walked around oh yeah
it's my I did what I had to do and I
just like went for it's like wait for
this I remember once I said I was
walking down some perfectly ordinary
random residential street I see a little
I was thirsty I sign
called coffee so I look is there a
coffee shop can't find it search finding
it to go down some stairs through doors
up some stairs to another one is like a
room and there's like a woman young
woman behind the counter and she makes a
cup of coffee that is so far and away
the greatest cup of coffee I've ever had
like nothing else is even close right
and then I tried to tip her as one would
and she got offended look I think you
know threw the money back was just like
this kind of an impossible to find in
the middle of nowhere coffee shop that
just kills any other but that's that's
Japan yeah it's like walking through a
fever dream I mean Japan is it's so much
fun so the podcast how did you decide no
doubt you have had people propose that
you do a podcast before yeah I mean I
still think we're at the very early
stages of adoption people I am that
think something like 15 or 17 percent of
the people in the US have listen to
podcasts it's a very relatively my early
days minority group at this point why
why and why now I mean what did you what
to what led to the decision well my
friend Jacob uh who runs the slate group
an old old friend of mine has they have
to panoply his there's big podcasting
company and he said you wanna do a
podcast I said no so come on do a
podcast so I said all right
it's really that and then I've got
really into it and realize how fun it
was and for all the reasons I talked
about earlier just how it's a different
way to tell story
what about it has been the most fun for
you I mean maybe we covered it already I
mean it is certain well it's a group
what is that I've never done a group
experience group thing before so
creating in a group was super novel I
mean I just I don't even go to meetings
Tim I there are no meetings in my life
and suddenly I went to meetings and I
didn't really know one hates meetings
but I was like whoa this is exciting
so everything was just kind of like and
then the idea of just the the ability to
generate emotion in a way you can't do
on the page is was
more than a revelation it was a kind of
I mean I was entranced by that
possibility it's transformative I mean
for me this podcast started as a lark
something to do in between extremely
exhausting book projects and when people
if any fans come up to me now when I'm
on the street at least nine times out of
10 probably even a higher percentage
talk about the podcast and not the books
and hopefully that's not because my
books are terrible that could that could
mean they're relatively speaking that is
the case but I think the emotional bond
the emotional response you're able to
create and the emotional bond that is
forged through the audio medium is just
yeah it's it's I have to imagine it's
it's some it's a reflective of some
hardwiring that we have as yeah so we
were telling machine is kind of an
amazingly powerful thing where would you
and maybe this is is to be kept a secret
but where would you in an ideal world
let's say two years from now what are
you doing an audio or not what is or
what does the podcast look like what is
your well I imagine I'll do another
season and I had played with the idea of
inviting someone to join the revisionist
history rubric and have someone else to
cup some episodes that try something
similar I mean this is a reason why I
can't be a kind of if I'm doing a
collective project let's make it just
really make a collective like not just
me dreaming up there so I thought about
that if I could find someone who you
know took it seriously and wanted was
have shared my but uh I don't know and
then you know can I make a living doing
it that's not a question so uh you can
certainly talk more about the last last
piece offline but I would say the answer
should be yes there's no reason why it
shouldn't be and that on the
second-to-last piece I would absolutely
encourage you to experiment with the
format because it's such a lightweight
relatively speaking
medium and format for doing that I mean
I've I've tried four or five different
formats some were complete strikeouts
yeah and some with in terms of the cost
of creation in terms of energy time
money etc to the output and impact on
listeners was so disproportionately
favorable I was like wow I'm really glad
I tried those [ __ ] because these
hadn't work but like the solo Q&A is
that I do sometimes as round twos with
guests start it off because if you want
talk about kind of a-- I was sick at the
time I did the Peter teal interview and
so ended up being this solo read of
sorts which was profound and hilarious
and great in different ways and I
realized oh wait a second I don't
actually have to be there for this to be
useful to listeners and say I hope you
experiment with that a last last real
question and then we'll wrap up here if
you had a billboard and could put
anything on it what would you put on
that billboard probably a picture of one
of my favorite runners on my phone I'm
sure it's on my phone oh yeah he's
obscured by all the all the icons but
who is that ash Belka prop rolled squid
smiler from Kenya
he's my screensaver for my picture on my
phone
I don't know I'm obsessed with the idea
that a track-and-field ought to be one
of our most popular sports and in fact
is our least popular sport so I would
love to I want I want to I want a day
when America's you know when the
American record holder in the 5k can
walk down the street and everyone will
come up to her and say you know Wow
can I have your autograph and she'll be
mobbed and you know that's what I want
to happen one day so do you have any
give any this this could seem like silly
question but do you have any quotes that
you live your life by er mantras in a
non whooooo kind of sense that are
meaningful to you they might just be
like heuristics rules of thumb thing
like that not really I mean kind of in a
playful way I used to love I really like
that I keep kind of myself going back to
that the legal adage difficult cases
make bad law
which I think it's an incredibly a site
for comment about how because where were
drawn to the difficult case one but you
shouldn't generalize from it and then we
can't that's this problem we run into in
political realm over and over again itís
political many wows but give an example
of that I I'm not sure I'm yeah failure
ah 9/11 it's a difficult case right
incredibly rare catastrophic event
catches us by surprise should you try to
generate policy exclusively from the
9/11 experience that's what we did what
do we do I think you mean a bunch of
really terrible mistakes right we spent
two trillion on a war that went nowhere
I made the world worse off we subvert at
our own civil liberties we created these
monolithic government agencies that God
knows what they're doing
are we actually safer than we were I'm
not sure that's a case where you if if
we had exercise some restraint and said
you know what you can't use a single
incident which was this bizarre outlier
and base the whole national security
policy of your country on it you have to
look at the at the long view take the
long view right
Obama is a very natural that kind of
thinking is very natural to him but he's
a difficult cases bad law kind of guy
he's like let's not overreact let's wait
and see that kind of thing which people
find very frustrating with him
but I like that notion similarly you
know it's it's about not overreacting to
to black swans you know to to outlying
events and also not choosing your your
case studies wisely that's I think what
it's really about when I suppose you
could also generalize it to your
personal life in many ways to I mean
just because you're mugged once doesn't
mean you should have a fundamental
distrust of every human being as you go
throughout life yes exactly exactly
right and yet and we I think we can go
further that just because you have been
traumatized in some way doesn't mean you
are permanently scarred right that
human beings are resilient they recover
and that's something that Sebastien also
brought up and not everyone shares this
opinion but given his extensive
experience with vets and soldiers he
felt like they should not be treated
like victims when they come back if they
suffer from PTSD for a whole host
reasons that I won't get into but this
has been so much fun
I I really think we could we could
continue talking for hours but I want to
be respectful your time Malcolm where
can people find the podcast where can
they find you on social media or
elsewhere where would you like them to
to check things out podcast is
revisionist history calm but anyway our
podcasts you can find revisionist
history and my twitter handle is just at
Gladwell I'm the only global out there
so I die but I tweet I'm an indifferent
tweeter but I I get into little moments
when I when I go off especially if
someone brings up the the myths and
policies of current higher education in
the United States so that gets me going
I remember Poe Bronson told me once I
asked at a QA this is before I had
written any books and I asked him what
he does when he has writer's block and
he said I write about what makes me
angry and occasionally I use that it
seems to work pretty well at least to
get me get me started
Malcolm thank you so much for the time I
really appreciate it thank you Tim and I
can't wait to to jump into the episodes
you mentioned of the podcast and I'll
probably just go from start to finish
that's I can be pretty linear that way
yeah
and to everybody listening you can find
links to richness history to everything
we discussed the books mentioned etc in
the show notes at 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast and until next
time and as always thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies calm this is the
training system that I am most obsessed
with at the moment and I don't get paid
any Commission's or anything like that
you may have heard coach summer on the
podcast who design the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming I've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and I feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim if you go to that
landing page gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim you can take a look at
the fundamentals course which I'll help
you diagnose your weakest points areas
to improve etc and I highly encourage
you take a look at this body weight
training system it is incredible
gymnastic bodies calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive
'we set it and forget it investing
service led by technologists for places
like Apple and world-famous investors it
has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealthfront
is in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
art great investing is a marathon not a
sprint and little things that you may or
may not be familiar with like automatic
tax loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal
they wanted to sponsor this podcast but
because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by wealth
front that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money at least for me
in the team and the company itself so I
am an investor and hope to
use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of
you